the armed forces mr james heapi joining
us now i've been very busy over the last
few days mr heaphy thanks for taking the
time to join us again this morning
reports in germany over the weekend that
russia could begin an invasion as early
as wednesday how seriously are we taking
that in the uk
very um and we've seen now
uh that there's 130 000 combat troops uh
around
ukraine's land borders there's thousands
more on amphibious shipping in the black
sea and as of sea
russia has concentrated artillery
missile systems and combat air in the
area and perhaps
more ominously although it grabs less
headlines all of the combat enablers the
logistics the fuel the medical supplies
the bridging assets are all also now in
place so the reason that the travel
advice changed uh on friday
and the urgency of the messaging since
is that the attack could effectively now
happen with no notice um that's why
we've told uk citizens to leave and as
you'd imagine that's why the diplomatic
effort is being redoubled and people in
this building are working very hard to
make sure that our response is properly
calibrated
yeah and your boss as we know has
cancelled his holiday
that's what our view is in the west but
have a listen to if you would please
what the ukrainian ambassador to the uk
told me on this program last week here
we go
believe personally that we are not there
yet and it can be avoided quite easily
and he is still raising the the sort of
hunt in the diplomatic negotiations
or doesn't
his view minister is that war doesn't
seem um to be
imminent um why do we think differently
well i've heard uh zelensky say this and
uh my ukrainian interlocutors in their
mod when i visited a few weeks ago
were saying the same and i i hope
they're right i hope that this is just
uh putin amassing forces for the
purposes of diplomatic leverage
and certainly nobody in the west wants
to unnecessarily cause alarm but by the
same token we have a responsibility both
to ukraine as an ally but also to our
citizens in ukraine to be clear on what
we know but my my nervousness k is if
this was indeed just a
play by vladimir putin to get a seat at
the negotiating table he had that when
he had 50 000 troops
on the border of ukraine
but he's kept on building them up
my fear is that it is now very imminent
indeed that's not to say that it is
definitely going to happen
i hope that diplomacy can win through uh
as challenging as the minsk uh agreement
is for the ukrainians it is
uh the framework around which a
discussion could proceed and there are
other
mechanisms from the cold war and since
that we could revive as confidence
building measures between russia and the
west so there are ways of getting out of
this diplomatically but we should be
absolutely clear you're seeing it on
open source it doesn't require um secret
intelligence to show you
that there is a very very worrying very
credible force now amassed around
ukraine and it's on that basis of course
that we're offering the travel advice
that we are and that causes the urgency
with which we're all working
you've written the times um this morning
minister i'm sure people will find an
interesting read talking about cool
heads time for cool heads and a clear
message to russia um we know that your
boss um spoke ben wallace spoke the
defense secretary um the on saturday i
think comparing putin to hitler
basically did he misspeak
no i i don't think he was making any
such direct comparisons either between
uh
individuals involved in this on the
russian side and certainly not with uh
allies uh of of as
ben was
expressing i think uh his frustration at
the apparent futility of
the
diplomatic process ben has been working
on this
for months now uh he has been
uh to the fore in the uk government in
advocating for support to ukraine
he drove hard to get the lethal aid
to ukraine to assist in their defensive
effort
he was in moscow on friday for a very
exacting meeting with minister shoigu in
which i thought he did very well but i
know both privately and as you've seen
publicly he's deeply concerned that all
of this
could be futile and
i can understand why he's so frustrated
the ukrainian ambassador let me quote
him again because after all of course
it's the people of ukraine that have
most to lose or gain depending on which
way you look in it um he was saying it's
not the best time for us to offend our
partners in the world reminding them of
this act which actually not brought
peace but the opposite it brought war so
you know
words
quite literally could cost lives he did
misspeak didn't he
well words words matter and i think ben
is well known to colleagues around
europe he has been traveling around all
over the place i'm certain that they
will know exactly what he meant and they
certainly know that he uh doesn't mean
them any uh insult or injury whatsoever
in fact quite the reverse ben has been
bringing nations together over the last
three months uh as the response has been
coordinated uh ben has done a fantastic
job at doing that and indeed the
ambassador himself went back out on
broadcast media yesterday evening to
clarify that actually um the ukrainians
know that ben wallace is
one of their very best friends in the
world
and very few people have done more than
him to support them over the last few
months
the ukrainian government very keen to
join nato we've known that for some time
but also hearing that they would
potentially
put that onto the back burner if it was
to avoid war do you think that's a
sensible decision
well look we've been very clear and as i
said in my
article in the times that any diplomatic
solution to this shouldn't be something
that compromises the
ukrainian government's sovereignty and
their ability to choose which alliances
they want to be a member of now if
ukraine decides that it is going to
offer that it won't become a nato member
we support that that's for the
ukrainians to decide and there are
countries like serbia that are not
members
of nato but with whom we seek to have a
good relationship similarly if ukraine
wanted to reserve its position and say
that in the future it may want to join
nato we would support that too because
that's what sovereignty is and that's
what we support
how many british nationals have left
ukraine and how many um have you not
been able to get in touch with
well it's impossible to know how many
have left so far because this is a very
different type of country to afghanistan
there is free movement across the border
of ukraine into
the european union and people can just
get in their cars and drive across
into poland the foreign office have had
a website
running for some time which has allowed
british nationals in ukraine to register
their details and thus allow the foreign
office to communicate directly with them
but let's be clear k um we are beyond
the time where i'm advising people to
register on a website i'm being very
very clear to people that they should
leave ukraine now whilst there are the
commercial means to do so and whilst the
motorways are available for them to
drive out over the border this isn't uh
a warning about something that could
happen in three months time this isn't a
warning that will be followed by further
warnings because greater imminence has
been uh has been reached this is a
warning because
minutes after putin gives the order
missiles and bombs could be landing on
ukrainian cities and that means british
citizens should leave now whilst they
have the opportunity to do so
what about those brits that have
recently had
babies children and they're saying they
can't get the paperwork together in
order to get out of the country what are
we going to do about that
so i saw that case being reported in the
media over the weekend and i have every
confidence that my colleagues in the
foreign office will have seen it
whilst the british embassy in kiev
has been reduced in its staffing as you
would expect given the threat
there is still consular support uh
available through the foreign office
here in london and uh in poland as well
so i'm sure that colleagues in the
foreign office will have seen that case
being reported and that people in those
circumstances will be helped
okay um you talk about bombs and bullets
seconds after putin gives the order to
that end klm um has already uh the flag
carrier for the dutch airline has
already said uh we're not doing any
flights to ukraine for now um air lingus
or lufthansa forgive me are already
looking at that as well what's the
government's advice to our flag carrier
british airways
well the government has given advice uh
on whether or not you should travel to
uh ukraine um but forgive me and i i
might be wrong but when we were looking
at options for my trip the other week i
i'm not absolutely sure that ba flies to
ukraine
oh okay
um i might be wrong but if you know
otherwise i'll answer the question but
i'm not i'm not absolutely sure it does
okay if they do should they still be
doing it
well i think uk airlines will be making
a judgment that is based on insurance i
think is what i've read from
other airlines uh over the weekend um
clearly there is a very real danger of
the airspace over ukraine um becoming
hostile ukraine even if they don't land
in kiev i would have guessed
well i think if you if you recall from
previous times where there have been uh
conflicts uh airlines have always sought
to avoid that airspace and that's not
because
they fear necessarily that they will be
targeted but um
it probably sounds quite obvious but you
know when an artillery shell is fired it
goes a long way up before it comes down
so too do missiles whiz backwards and
forwards and then of course there's all
the combat aircraft
going around and combat aircraft do not
identify themselves on radars in the
same way as civilian aircraft do so i
think exactly
the question minister yeah so it's just
that i think it's a standard operating
procedure for airlines to adjust their
routes to avoid conflict zones certainly
i recall
flying to the far east when the iraq and
afghanistan conflicts were at their
height
and
routes were clearly selected to avoid
those those airspaces given what you
know is now the time for our flag
carrier to stay away from ukrainian
airspace
well that's an operational judgment for
them as it stands today there is nothing
in the airspace above
as it stands today there's nothing in
the airspace above ukraine um it's not
my place to live on your show offer
advice on whether or not an airline
should fly through a certain country's
airspace but i'm certain that the
department for transport the airlines
themselves and indeed the civil aviation
authorities of uh the countries uh that
neighbor ukraine will all be making a
judgment but for the time being
there is nothing in ukrainian airspace
that would stop you from flying over it
i think it's very intense time for
european security we can all agree uh
with that it's now the right time for
the metropolitan police commission
commissioner to have stepped down in a
fit of peak
i'm not sure i quite see the connection
between policing in london and a moment
of acute geopolitical crisis in europe
involved in terrorism
she's also
involved in terror threats in the uk as
well isn't she she's in charge of i
think i think the metropolitan police
force continues to have full
functionality even in the interregnum um
but clearly a new commissioner will be
appointed uh as that process uh reaches
its conclusion
okay well maybe we'll try this one see
if you've got a stronger view on this
given that the uh we have seen the
pictures of the prime minister final
question um at parties we've seen him
with tinsel uh sat next to somebody with
tinsel we've seen him eating crisps and
there we go we've seen him um with the
bottle of open bottle of very nice
champagne on the desk as well
um
should he just accept the fine pay it
move on
well i
he needs i think to be found guilty by
an investigation by the police first
doesn't he
if it looks like a duck etc
well i i i don't know that i accept that
kate and on the one hand you know we've
we've had a investigation by a senior
civil servant she found calls to refer a
number of lines of investigation to the
police which they've now done
i think that
you like many members of the public and
parliamentarians are
keen to see what the police conclude i
certainly don't think the prime minister
should volunteer his culpability his
argument is that he is not culpable um
we should wait and see what the police
come back with
okay just a final thought what's your
interpretation of that photograph then
if it's not him drinking
champa or being in the same place with
somebody with tinsel around their neck
taking part in a quiz and champagne
there and crisps on the desk
i don't know that is a snapshot in time
i don't know whether the prime minister
has walked into that room whilst the
other two people in the photograph are
engaged
we saw him sat down at the computer as
well didn't we that very same laptop
well you mean you're asking me to offer
an analysis of a photograph that i i
don't know the context of that
photograph um and to be honest okay and
i i don't mean to sound right um if
there are photographs that i'm going to
spend time worrying about today it's the
photographs of russian troop formations
on the ukrainian border that's what's
fixing me that's what's taking up my
time i make no apology for that this is
a moment of acute geopolitical crisis
and all of us in government have got a
job today
in which in which case i must let you
get on with it thank you very much
indeed for joining us on the program
thank you